hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to fatal frame - I'm
sorry for the long delay I have been
unfortunately out of time to be able to
record in fact today was very busy and
I'm actually recording this past
midnight and also I actually know what's
coming up next because I started
recording without actually hitting my
record button I'm definitely sure that
it's doing it now because I wasted a
whole lot of time and that's
exceptionally unfortunate because it's
actually after midnight right now and I
am very very tired I had a very long day
today I was up at 4:30 in the morning
just to dick around and make videos that
I forgot to process from last night uh
actually I didn't forget I just kind of
got lazy and went see a movie and
whatnot which is fine because I got a
relaxing day but unfortunately means
that I didn't get my work done and I
always need to get my work done so that
I can relax at a later date so I don't
oh hello what we got here this I didn't
see a mom who's hiding in the shadows
here oh hey and we you don't look pinned
down you look standing upright don't try
to fool me I am known to solve mysteries
here and there be the way so I was up
early today and then I had a doctor's
appointment then I had a whole bunch of
stuff let me just tell you about my
whole day because I know you're so
interested what I did know they did the
help I remember you you were just no
lady looking for cranberries man tired
and cold man wait I just took a picture
of you I just very clearly took a
picture of you Oh Pookie
ectoplasmic goo over the shivering woman
cuz she cooled that's a doll and you
can't pull me otherwise okay so in an
attempt to not look like a total idiot
III some at what nowhere I was supposed
to go immediately after this because we
did make progress after looking like a
complete idiot was like my basically nut
job on the internet that's all I do
every day all day every day all day
every day all day every day not
what pardon me I also know it's coming
up in this next room it's really really
fun experience and I can't wait to share
with all you wait where is it was near
ahead wait wait for it oh wait
hello BAM Katya this isn't the fun
experience I was telling you about this
is just a fun experience that I
discovered before corner woman she's
standing in the corner suffering her
punishment
Derry her Derry corner lady how dare are
you how dare you wait for it before for
there we go here we go hi ah and then
that's all I can say about that but I
have to go all the way down here because
I spent like 10 minutes yelling at this
lady to sound very upset
all he does is crawl on the ground like
a creepy creepy lady that's all she does
that's all she does just crawls around
like a creepy lady and it was her fatal
frame is like the weirdest thing ever
like I can just take pictures of her
down here because she's not really gonna
do anything and I might as well pittle
away some damage on her but what she
does just watch is wait wait wait this
way it's gonna be nuts it's gonna be
like the greatest thing ever just exude
wait did you wait it'll be so worth the
wait
ah here she goes ready ready oh I was
gonna picture of like her crotch which
is not what I'm out for here it was
really like
picture that I was trying for a long
time when I was yelling at her let's
just basically yelling early lady get up
off the ground I only got her feet oh oh
no that that jostle me no don't grab my
ankles no my ankles my one weakness no
okay
so yeah this was like this is how I
spent the majority of the stuff that
didn't get recorded which in all honesty
you guys probably would have wanted to
see because it was what should have
taken like two minutes to get through
took me like 15 minutes just to slog
through this one fight okay she's going
up is she like whoa whoa ah that was it
okay I never managed to actually catch
her when she was looking out and let me
just get her
I've almost got her down the whole way
but she's gonna disappear oh god damn it
the sword get oh no oh no my ankles
they're vulnerable
oh no oh oh there we go
there we go good texture give me that
core shot oh no it's just beat the wind
out of her it didn't quite get her I'm
glad they're giving me this really
really weird body position for this lady
for me to take pictures up oh god damn
it I can never hit that in the entire
time I've been doing this I've never
been able to get it just finish her off
and move on I'm getting frustrated again
fighting his lady again you been
big annoying lady all right so that was
that fight I'm glad you were all here
with me I'm glad you could enjoy that
I'm here to entertain that's what I'm
here for
it's just a little tired because frankly
it's really late and I wanted to go to
bed and I got pretty far into the last
recording before I had to shut down and
realize oh I'm an idiot I didn't
actually do it I was really disappointed
and disheartened but either way um the
other thing that I did today is I built
a set with the cyndago guys and I got a
lot of supplies for a shoot that we're
doing on Saturday and can you just go in
the right direction lady I'm not in the
mood okay
so we were building a set for what we
were doing sorry I just had to get that
out of me
you know you guys spent a lot of time
yelling at me for the things that I do
wrong
I gotta yell myself sometimes and yell
at this lady for the things she's doing
wrong cuz I can i can't take it
sometimes be the way we were blending
except for a shoot that we're doing
pretty soon and it's gonna be a lot of
fun because i'm very very excited for
what we managed to do it's gonna be a
bunch of fun and you guys are really
gonna enjoy it
but before that we have to get to
certain points that just leaps back to
where I was before
I'm very sweaty very sweaty I don't
remember where I needed to go after this
I I kind of realized pretty soon after
this but um the last thing I did today
was I I spent some time with rhett and
Link to do a your ear biscuits sound
podcast and I also managed to do oh I
went backwards I didn't need to go this
way I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
going the wrong way
I didn't hear biscuits podcast and then
I did I did a song biscuits with them
that's supposed to be really fun oh
that's right there's a there's a door
down this way that's right that's right
yeah I apologize like I'm just kind of
out of it because I was so sorely
disappointed in fact that I was just
like I was so close like to making a
really good episode and I filled it with
great jokes and all this crap and I was
like oh yeah
this is gonna be great even though I
wasted 15 minutes on that stupid monster
that should have taken me like two okay
there's beautiful for doing screen
standing beyond the chest of drawers
is a picture of crimson butterflies
fluttering below the flowers on it
alrighty then small mere stands covered
with red cloths are lined up here beyond
them there's a pair of dolls everything
seems to come in pairs in this room
almost as if it's a room for twins twin
rooms it's the twins rooms it's for the
twins the twins you're about to see now
wait not now
wait there's a delay hey wait everybody
wait or by the way for it's gonna be so
shocking when you see it just wait just
wait just wait
if this lady wouldn't recommend oh wait
no sitting not the dolls did the twins
get this get that way you're supposed to
be a picture of both of them
we got a ding dong damn bad are you we
got a dings bat we got a Diggs how about
the controls work I'm too tired to put
up with this ball my hands closed around
a zombies neck we soft warm alive my
grip seemed to cause her so much pain
the very end the veiled priest came to
help me
but as ami said she wanted only me to do
it I became one with Asami but now she's
gone I can't talk about it anymore
father brought us ami back all I could
do was apologize she forgave me the
killing is over now no more I'll never
hurt anyone again I'll never let anyone
kill again father says ami has been
possessed and he's trying to kill her
he's trying to kill a zombie I won't let
him do it I won't let that happen so
that's a really messed-up story about
how some of these twins have to go
through these rituals to get to the
other side glowing crystal all right
this is about where I realized that I
was not up to snuff on the recording
said it but hey we're making more better
progress than we were before
toy way oh I got a new stoner I didn't
listen to this Oh Stuart
oh then don't all right then you get a
whisper in my ear some more then don't
don't kill anyone
don't do it especially not me your twin
creepies you creepy Tweenies it's
want--we any creepies so creepy all
right whatever I'm sure that I'm and I
encountered them before okay we're
officially the new territory here anyway
like I said I did in ear biscuits and I
sound biscuits podcast I know her who oh
the twin
well then don't kill anyone why do you
want to kill
why must you kill you're creepy okay
please get away from me oh god oh god
what do I do Oh Oh God
Oh God uh why do you oh hi
hello hey
okay ah well they didn't do any damage
uh you slumped over like it did damage
by don't ever did any damage they come
from behind me oh crap where are you
where are you whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa what the heck e heck where am
I now
whoa whoa whoa you did say there were a
lot of oh hey hi hi hi hi you didn't say
you're gonna be hind by the curtains
it's not fair playing dirty I need to
smoke some herbs I need to shove a whole
lot of herbs down my throat because I
can't handle this I'm far too stressed
there's something on the floor thank you
I'll just be on my way then thank you
wait can I not damage them or something
cause I know what I'm supposed to do
here I didn't kill anybody don't put
that [ __ ] on me didn't do that huh try
to tell me who I am simply be she'll
shut by a powerful force what about my
big strong arms it's a powerful force of
pushing this to open doors where is it
oh hey hey how's it going kiddo good
jump out of me BAM
damn it why is this not doing any damage
am i doing something wrong here I feel
like I'm doing something wrong I didn't
kill you I haven't even done the liquor
damage to you I'll be happy the day I
could kill you guys they like to come
through the walls the weirdos okay where
are they is it is it bull Don just the
ones where are they
there's one what's the other I feel like
the other ones is gonna crawl up my butt
yeah they come through the walls the
weirdoes where's the other one we're
supposed to do yeah there we go
why did that do anything why did that do
wait am I only supposed to hit the right
one he's like this one not gonna do it I
think I think I heard yeah I heard the
other one it was very nearby I was gonna
walk right into it where are you at this
is the one that I just hit because it
responded after
and this will be the one that I want to
hand right here
come at me bro BAM I said I should equip
the block haha okay I gotta hit both of
them okay that makes sense okay so I
gotta hit one after another that's it
I got your number now I know what's up
and uh damn it
uh ah my thigh Oh No there's grabby
hands don't grab me with your grabby
hands where the hell am I
I keep getting turned around out there
come here
Oh with you why'd you disappear right
here oh oh wait they're just stupid why
you just appeared I saw you oh they're
here come on lunge whoa lunge lunge at
me brah
oh no your picture your run we I did it
where's the other one we're dealing
oh no that was it that was it
those it I got it yeah I did it I
figured it out I probably didn't do as
well as people think I did I didn't
realize it and the only way to get the
fatal frame was to hit one to have the
other one charge at you their little
grabby grabby hands
now that endeavor is out of the way I
can actually get two will away
what ghosty goes in here oh hey you do
look familiar I wonder if there was some
reason for that BAM oh no God a
different place shows in the photo
oh no well this is gonna take me forever
you can see something that looks like a
family altar have I seen a family I
think I did to your family altar didn't
that I don't know tired so I wouldn't
know if I did or not alright then that's
good to know how you creepy-ass thatch
is doing there's a doll on display here
it's just about the size of a real child
okay good great there are two buttons
carved with family crests on the box leg
stretcher behind the doll you tried
pressing them but nothing happens
okay good at least you're trying the
buttons it could have been the
self-destruct button but it doesn't
matter just press it anyway there's a
doll on display here it's missing its
head and arms I didn't even know is
missing his arms if it were hold it in
the doll next to it would probably be
twins okay great good for that my eyes
are having trouble staying open the
worst part is I have to record another
video after this well I'm gonna be super
loopy dusty dolls are visible in the
candle light maybe his room was used for
his vigil boobies yeah the only reason
I'm up so late is I've been keeping a
really good schedule is at this point
with the with the ear biscuits and the
the song biscuits it's just we've spent
so much time recording a song and you
guys are really gonna like the song when
it comes out I can't tell you much about
it but you guys are really gonna like
the song oh boy
akane damaged the mechanism to access
the passageway and she took butter the
dull I have to restore the to indulge
normal and drop the possessed doll of
zombie into the wall descent as we heard
back to hell but that path was the only
way to the wall
oh I thought it was gonna say more of
the name that shall not be spoken name
they're all female Japanese dolls
without a single male ha more for me
my Mew meow was probably a lady
maybe this room was used for some
special purpose oh you think oh maybe
huh you think I don't if huh I can't
tell the whole team's been about twins
twin statues twin dolls I don't know oh
I can't handle this I can't deal I'm not
able to deal I'm underling I'm
undateable can't deal with this it's
only been 15 there's only been 17
minutes I got a long way to go you under
the lock rooms on the door good where is
this lady
where is leave me wait tell me where is
it oh the film projector okay well I got
I got a new thing I got a new thing I
need to swap this one what you guys did
did I see three how did I just look at
this wall instead of the movie okay
there we go okay twins are running away
angry mob chasing after the twins
justice has been done leading him into
the sacrificial chamber that's the pit
of war throne and what who is filming
this by the way Oh people ain't happy
oh no the boys gone loose hello okay so
I'm guessing they went through with the
ceremony and something horrible happened
as it always does let me just make sure
I have
have I seen this I don't know if I saw
this did I see this who's that who's up
there is that the kusabi is that the
kusabi is that the kusabi which
apparently means sacrifice if you didn't
know is that the kusabi okay throw them
into the pit oh there's the twins is a
weird guy oh yeah there we can go back
now there are two other doors on the
other end of the hallway I need to
explore so I know what I'm doing her a
progress I'm in she doing pretty good I
got to admit for me being tired then
again I kind of did explore half of what
I've done already so I can't be too
proud of myself I've already done that
and I will admit I got lost first time
thumbs up against that damn ghost for
like that goddamn it it's loopy loopy
loopy loopy loopy ah
NEADS need to need to sleep ah the good
thing is I don't have a lot scheduled
tomorrow I do not have a lot scheduled
oh I think there's a ninja sex party
shoot then I might be joining them on it
should be a lot of fun hopefully
hopefully not if I don't that I'm just a
crazy person I miss kissing Rasmus Brown
asleep
oh this leads back so so that's good
right
I do what I needed to do oh I need to
look for where that picture is I totally
forgot about that okay
Bam Bam this means I'm still recording
right I better still be freaking
recording I'm still recording okay good
good good god okay so good good great
okay all right wait I need to even look
at the photo because I've told it forgot
what it was like family altar oh that's
right family altar okay where have I
seen a family altar oh you know look in
the map because that helped me the last
time there's got to be like something
with altars somewhere okay is that it
deluxe tatami room is kind of right next
to me
I'll call sir um hallway of contrast
that's a cool name I guess for losers
twins room it was the twin drum twins
room room for twins it was called the
twins room for twins for the twins rooms
where dad's room doll room that leads
back to the way that I first came in oh
shut up I'm about out a revelation
everyone's gonna be so proud of me
family altar room family altar room
family altar room it's a rum for the
family altar hooray okay let's go there
I'm ready
where was that we're here Yes No maybe
so I don't know who knows these things
was over here here right yeah I was
right here yay family altar who'd have
thought it would have been so well label
oh wait oh wait no who where we going
we're looking oh
hidden man
hey I just want I didn't know if I need
to take another picture I didn't
actually see him in the picture in the
last one as if what's really alive for
some reason subtitles on right now what
do you mean I'm wasting film what was
that was that an actual door spiderwebs
cover the family altar there seems to be
space on either side of the altar but
it's so dark you can't see what about
what about this flashlight I'm flat
flashing right in there I'm flashing so
hard in there you can't tell me I'm not
the battery whoops kept the family
outside there's a mortuary tablet a
rosary and prayer bell on the table is
what looks like a sutra written in the
open book which can trina is it the
commas karma karma sutra Karma Sutra
yeah and not bro me every young girl
young lady you don't look at that
actually how old is she like that's my
big I don't know how old this girl
actually is like as much as I would
assume that the Japanese would throw a
teenage girl into this mix like I I
don't know anymore
oh now what about their candle what it
is too dark there's multiple light
sources in here okay
Oh anyway where was that where's that
man he was in the room next to this one
whoa what
why wave me were you doing to me
wait what you can't just do that
you can't just plop a twin in front of
me and call it a day you got to
acknowledge it in some way
I didn't even exhaust me oh I don't know
what's wrong with you me oh my you all
of you weird weird weird weird people
what the hell is that supposed to mean
why even do to be what are you doing I
can't
Oh No oh good Oh 14 film I need that cuz
I've been using too much of it all right
whoops would they say the arms legs and
head of a doll have been thrown
carelessly on the shelf good let us stay
carelessly disassembled there are doll
fingers cord screws and other small
parts organized in the small drawer
there isn't anything that looks
especially useful okay cool
there's a head in that pile is that the
head I need to put on the statue there's
no book I saw a zombie even though she
should be in the road now she was asking
me to kill the asami doll that made a
great mistake the Twins had at last
become one again
I was wrong to make that doll I think
zombie was trying to tell me where the
head and hands of the dollar hidden
they're hidden in a box don't worry the
house oh as helpful in a box
who wants a bat backs since by shape no
whoa whoa I don't wanna I don't wanna
yeah uh-huh you're weird oh god damn
who's getting creepy like legitimately
this is getting really creepy I don't
like this Dolomites door Oh mad
not a doll thank you not my child I know
oh wait hang on ah must kill what a
ghost look Mike you made your other
child kill the other child or not why
did you - I don't know in a box a box
why is everyone so obsessed with
murdering but anyway what I'm trying to
say is oh good a ghost they can't exist
it's impossible no I refuse to believe
it
it can't be true say it ain't so awesome
I don't know still tired oddly enough
I'm still tired those creepy-ass twins
are gonna keep prodding at me that
actually is legitimately creepy whoa
whoa you're real you're real you're real
you're real you're real where are you
whoa where yeah help over there
what are you doing hey you're not
supposed to be out here whoa whoa god
damn it you come up low I forget that
you're a child and if you're way way
down what was that yeah I need to smoke
some more herbs
okay so I didn't kill anybody you killed
what are you killing anyway ma'am are
you the real one there's the other one
making a charge better not be wrong you
there why do I want now I didn't kill
nobody
if you killed somebody yeah that's what
I thought
are you both there you're both their
agent I'll just count to four two four
one do for one sale at the nightmare
store
oh I got Bossier I did I did it I got
both of them
whoa whoa whoa someone was close
hey how's it going my name is Mario our
I'm the Ghostbuster are you gonna call
why haven't I made a thumbnail of me as
the Ghostbuster yet I have a net whoa
stop hip hop hippity hop hip hop a
I'm a baby I'll goes tell me why haven't
I made a thumbnail of me as Ghostbuster
yet if that wasn't a lot of work I'd
probably do it for this one
whoops didn't mean to do that making
those thumbnails I've actually been
putting a lot more work into him lately
they are a lot of work okay so my clue
is they're in a box somewhere over the
rainbow now where was a box the store 'm
away clock halt twins rooms there were
boxes in the twins room they would make
sense that they might be in the twins
rooms so my options are the twins rooms
the storage room the picture no okay
wouldn't be on this side
I went in both of these with all of
these the hanging doll room that might
have something but I don't know if I
need to go back there uh I'm just gonna
go to the twins room first and then
cycle cycle around to the store actually
no I'll go I'll go this way first cuz I
don't know if I check that side little
storage area did I
I don't remember besides I can save
again
whoa hey whoa we're we're done we're
done
why are you doing the creepiest game
Jesus balls yeah ten Mangal er your
flabby dubler well you think you're
doing
goddamn I'm tired and I'm getting
freaked out like literal legitimate ly
I'm here all alone and like goddamn
flippin me and I don't like this this
game this game didn't start off all that
scary to me but like it's gotten
progressively more scary when your bike
Lou something that looks like a human
head is on the ground where the girl is
standing well I don't know what was in
there I can't see through a door
how did I get that a no fell from the
lower part of the doll it seems to be
written by the dollmaker a kanay has
become a remaining to comfort her i'll
make a doll it looks like his ami she
has been emotionless since the day of
the ritual i'll make the doll look
exactly like his ami so that when they
are together no one will be able to tell
them apart
great Akane never leaves his Ami's side
even for one second always whispering
things to her that's normal it's a doll
but whispering is normal I don't know
what she says but at least she seems to
salute me slowly returning to her former
self oh oh okay other way around if we
didn't have this ritual as AMI wouldn't
have become a butterfly and Akane
wouldn't have lost her spirit so what
was in here can I go in here I can't
remember I'm so tired I don't remember
so this is boxes okay just boxes I
should have known that oh man this swing
game actually is really creepy like I
will admit now that I'm now more than
ever just cuz it's way late at night
when I'm playing this and just cuz I'm I
know i'm all alone where I am and wait
was this a dollar yes okay so here now I
can put the doll head on there well I
don't have the arms yeah maybe we could
take one arm from this one oh so I don't
have the eyes or the arms so I just need
to go around and find the other parts
then they can't be far I'm willing about
the other one might actually be in the
twins room in some capacity which was
over here question mark
no this is a projector was damnit don't
start playing things automatically
that's just weird
you're like a Nexus move in here okay so
I need to go back to the okay there's a
door that way through I got I got I got
I got I got I got I got again look at me
I got I'm so smart again I get it I got
it have some pity on me oh my back hurts
I'm getting old man 25 about about time
to check out a life I guess huh been a
long road if i margall airs gotta get
old eventually sprout some gray hairs go
bald anybody here anybody in here any
eyeballs eyes eyeballs balls of eyes the
testicles of the head you know what I'm
talking about
horrible done I get that before oh I
think I remember getting that the first
time playthrough but it's all blurring
together at this point I don't remember
power do I need to remember
my fellow Americans do I need to
remember I don't know what I've done
already whatever they do if I did what
am I done in what haven't I didn't do I
need to go guide me guide me oh I
probably need to go back upstairs that's
right cuz yeah there's a whole nother
floor so if I go back upstairs I'm
probably gonna where does that lead from
in there ah ah I should probably go
upstairs but let me just explore this
area first I'm gonna go down to the hang
I'm gonna go the hanging doll room
because it seems like there might be
something there if I was going to look
for doll parts a beautiful place with
hanging adult oh this way let's meet by
the grand rigor there's no crazy houses
you'd be crazy Margo I'm just gonna
pirouette oh well I guess I can't do
that then it's a nevermind I don't
encourage me if L buy a crate for ghosts
there's a morgue okay owner if L see
that lady that was crawling on her back
the whole time
oh I hope she can fall over and over
again on my head over and over again
again and again they'd get it again I
mean there wasn't anything else to it
I'm not I'm not reading this wrong I
need the head and also eyes and arms
there's got to be a place where there
are all of those okay this is where you
were you give me any more secrets lady
yeah you're so weird with your face why
are your face so weird I'm not talking
about the Japanese it's talking about no
you touched it but nothing out of the
ordinary occurred is it just an ordinary
doll why did you touch it why would you
just touch it and say those things why
do you think that to yourself that just
makes me more weirded out about it
the fact that you're like touch it is it
just an ordinary doll probably I am so
relieved now at nothing bad happening to
me oh here we go here we go here we go
we got oh that sounds like a thing okay
let me actually try to see where that is
instead of just Oh
well that sounds bad well that sounds
bad
it sounds bad hey little girl hey hey
know something that looks like a human
arm is on the ground where the girl was
standing Oh dolls right I gotta find
another arm Jesus last night I heard
footsteps I thought it was Akane but it
was really a commie walking by herself
Akane I spent so much time thinking of
her sister a spirit must have taken over
the doll it is said that when a spirit
takes residence an adult can steal the
soul of others Akane isn't a person
anymore she's like a doll controlled by
a zombie she keeps repeating I don't
want to kill over and over she looks so
much like my daughter the zombie must be
killed again
those are great that's a great leap of
logic going from one thought to the
other I really appreciate it and respect
the maturity of what you're thinking
right now
also your cry
easy-hold x rays where does I undid the
lock that was on the door and did the
lock that was on the door okay I undid
it digit I undid you did oh I'm getting
a faint blue glow where am I going
what am i doing where am I going where
did it go we're gonna go go cotton eye
Joe was a song back when we're ever
gonna wear him ago where we go oh yeah
there were boxes in the front area here
yeah II he ha ha ha I get your boxes I
take your boxes I take them I take them
for myself yes I left no I will not I
don't care how much you keep asking me
no you don't need a sub miss dude for me
at me I am part of gardening now I am
one yet we're reaction yay
chi i ll AIT kill that stupid doll okay
sure
sounds good now you have both arms on
the head this must be all the doll parts
except for the eyes you know somebody I
remember the eyes you should some about
the eyes before us will remember we're
gonna be broom I think this actually
leads right to where I need to go so
this is actually off you look at me we
look at me I'm a vision tin whatever no
why do you do that why did you that this
is creepy don't be creepy are you gonna
be creepy don't be creepy stop being
creepy don't be creepy leggy being
creepy alright let's finish this up
let's give it the OL one-two punch right
in the gonads or I guess in the head and
arms whatever you put the doll together
but nothing happens the note said that
putting the doll together should make it
work but
how about pushing a bit well I'm glad I
did this this has got infinitely more
creepy why maybe you need something else
- if only had to some design plans or
something oh yeah so weird so weird why
does it have to be like dolls and
mannequins I don't like it oh okay we're
in where could I find some plans I mean
back in the doll room or the twins room
there was like a bookshelf that had some
information on it or that I couldn't
read right what's that in here than here
or somewhere else
umm I can't read them where am I
supposed to go oh maybe I just need to
go back to the dolls the doll maker's
room maybe that's it
and let me BRB or I won't be RB I'm just
gonna talk over this because I don't
feel like I don't feel like giving
myself more editing work yeah spin that
way that's a good idea for the control
scheme that is great no
oh so I'm frustrated I'm to the point
where I'm very easily act I don't like
being worked I don't want to be act what
about back in here is there something in
here that I could possibly need please
pretty please show me your secrets oh oh
here we go we got where's this ghost to
go oh I see well okay I knew it had to
be something back here
hello twinsies sounding chosen the photo
it looks like twins facing each other
and one strangling the other one oh
there we go
it was hidden in the ectoplasm that's
what it was a book appeared in the print
remains open the doll's eyes and give
the shrine maiden a soul when the two
shrine maidens face each other the
bridge through the underground opens up
if he's one of those wind-up clocks
imported from the West the different
tried maiden mechanism the Kuro shrine
maidens move right down to three o'clock
and left doll to nine o'clock right
button right doll 1.5 hours forward left
button 1.5 hour Ford left button right
doll one boy five hour Ford left all
three hours back when the shrine maiden
face the earth bridge that connects the
house will be passable seems overly
complicated Dutch bound shrine maidens
move the right doll of three o'clock
we've left out in nine o'clock yeah
right button right doll one hour forward
left our 1.5 hour Ford left button right
down two hours backwards left all 4.5
hours backwards when the shrine maidens
face sky bridge will the connects house
will be passable
okay so that's a clue for a different
house that's a Tachibana house this is
the one that I'm looking at right now
though so I need to make him three and
nine the doll soul is needed to make the
mechanism work I could create the other
parts again but I could never duplicate
that soul I can't let that he'll his
creature gets his hand on the soul the
soul is the key I'll have to keep it
safe with me
okay give me your soul oh why did it go
over there what why did it Oh
is that the first like jump-scare
jump-scare this game that oh you're not
gonna be able to look at that no you
weren't bugged by that at all were you
oh I don't like this at all
oh I don't know why must say also the
stores over now good good I was
wondering when I was gonna be open
oh that appeared on the floor okay whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa Ginga Gege okay cool
what did you say you know what I'm gonna
pan let me do this first I'm gonna swap
out my camera for
the Meijer the blast
yeah it's AMA good I should all also
upgrade my camera but I'll do that half
for this fight where yeah buddy whoa
whoa hey hey how's it going there how's
it going there friend oh wait it's gonna
okay Wow alright that's weird what right
what happened what happened oh what how
what is that I don't know it got me whoa
whoa hey whoa whoa back up there old man
good evening ma'am let me give you a
blast air blast on the back
tell me where's your where's your fatal
frame yeah where'd you go still
somewhere in front of me
yeah yeah come on finish this fight
don't be running away from me hope there
is
come on give me a good shot give me a
good shot give me a good shot
give me good BAM somehow that counted
I'll take it
whatever I'm good with it where it's
gonna look where you go there you
we had we had buddy-boy we had old man
come out and dance show me your moves
from the 1920s show me all those hips
displace are you doing way over there
weirdo
come over here there you fight like a
man
fight like a man give me a good shot
good good yeah you're good good chat oh
don't run away again I know you make the
dolls you creepy whispering weirdo
that's a doll oh oh hey has he won their
floaty dolls why did i zoom in a little
bit but oh god damn it that's cool and
all where's this a tiny floating doll
where is this goddamn guy well there is
what give me a good shot
what come on get gimme gimme gimme the
air get away from your creepy weirdo
well maybe I need to get him now oh come
on
I had him on the ropes how's he keep
getting away from oh come on
that god damn it it's all friggin weird
oh you better not moving in where is he
moving out there hey buddy
don't blast you anyway BAM I'm gonna
leave in twenty eight damage goddamn it
you son of a [ __ ] you old weirdo
you know what apparently it's easier to
just look for him oh there you are
creepy creeper
got another one boom Oh combo shot
to eat combo I got them fatal frame baby
I didn't know that I need to take the it
would I didn't know it was been easier
whoa
all right what kind of doll did it come
from I guess you can kind of guess first
I have to kill the doll by hanging it
then I must throw it back into the wall
it knows this and it's controlling Akane
trying to kill me I have to throw it in
even if seeing them on blinds me my
daughter must die again and Akane must
relive the pain of losing her sister if
we didn't have this ritual no one would
have to feel this kind of pain
well good they don't have the original
anymore you dingus okay Merkel the
switch equipment umm swap powerup lenses
allows you to equip up to three powerup
lenses at once
oh cool that means I can sweat between
them on demand instead of everything go
in the menu that's actually pretty handy
and a spirit orb okay I'll upgrade my
equipment later but I now have the eyes
which I'm assuming is all I need to make
the dolls move and then I press the
buttons to make them rotate until they
get three to nine so I know what I need
to do for the next episode and this is
actually where I wrap it up and I'm very
happy because they could actually stop
recording for a little bit and then I
can focus on the other video that I need
to do then edit them then wait for them
to get done rendering and then upload
them and then wait for them to get done
uploading oh hey you can't just appear
there yet dingleberry what am I supposed
to do about you oh you're gone now are
you you're gone huh you're gonna I don't
think at all now Weist your tricks area
Trixie tricks all right so anyway oh
goodness gravy ah it was a good episode
too so thank you for bearing through my
tiredness I made a ton of progress like
I'm actually surprised I didn't get lost
all that much and I progress way past
where I'd already done so it's pretty
good for me so thank you all so much for
watching hope you guys enjoyed this
episode I'm still kicking myself for not
hitting the record button I'm just that
tired but either way thank you again
everybody check out the other video
games that I've done other long series I
hope you're enjoying this one and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye or I'm wrong in there just
everywhere okay here's the bridge
wait no did I cross this bridge wait is
this the same bridge wait a minute I was
going on then it's oh oh oh locked on
target
good I'm gonna murder him